[Music]
hello and welcome to year-in-review a
chance to look back at 2018 s biggest
news stories joining me for the program
are the editor of The Times Literary
Supplement Stig Abel the Evening
Standard columnist and comedian Asia has
a weaker the sun's political editor Tom
Newton done and last but not least
journalist and documentary maker Jenny
Clayman welcome to all of you so in the
next hour then we'll take you through
our guest choices for the year's
greatest heroes it's wickedest villains
and do some crystal ball gazing as to
what could happen in 2019 but before all
of that we start with our panelists
picks for the story of the year and Tom
we start with you you have chosen one
that is very much unfinished and still
unfolding its success being a
Westminster washer and terrible
Westminster boy it would have to be of
course so brexit has as we know consumed
everything in Westminster it's been
almost the only story it's been actually
and as we speak now the only thing the
British government is doing everything
else has now being parked since
mid-december we slipped into the No Deal
contingency plans being activated in
full and the story for me because
arguably you could say well not actually
much has happened with brexit we haven't
breasted yet and there still isn't a
deal we'd be talking about that all year
what has happened and that the most
interesting part of it for me has been
the almost total failure of the
political establishment to come together
work together even within their own
parties to agree something the political
as some have almost University failed in
their job to lead and lead the country
into a certain direction up to the point
now that we're less than a hundred days
to go
anything could happen next year we're
facing the meaningful vote in January
and the conclusions of that are totally
unknown far to the point that we don't
even know with for sure the breaks
itself will happen yes and what we've
seen is the morphing of tourism A's
position from
bricks it means brexit last year the
Lancaster House speech to the sort of
compromise that we've seen in the
withdrawal agreement ayesha which
doesn't seem to get the support of the
House of Commons well I think the big
reveal of this year is it just really
shows how stuck Parliament is the maths
really isn't there for anything to get
through at the movement is very very
gridlocked and I think one of the
failures of the Prime Minister I think
she's a detail person I think it's not
that she hasn't worked hard at this
she's almost quite a civil servant Prime
Minister but I think she's she is
particularly talked up on the detail I
don't think it is a cock-up in the
details which I don't think I think the
politics don't work for breaks are I
think the details could be done and I've
spoken to civil servants in Brussels who
say actually there is there is a deal to
be done but can you get your politicians
in London to agree this deal and the
problem is they can't nobody is happy
whether you're a brexit ear this feels
like a huge betrayal to you if you're a
remainer then this is egregious because
it's so sort of worse than what we've
got that it's sort of it's managed to
unite the country in sort of dismay so
it's that politics is that breaks its
fault rather than the politicians world
because ultimately if it's a 50/50 split
there's no political impetus for anyone
to be brave because everyone can just
see the downside that seems to me jeremy
corbyn's position every time he thinks
he could actually come up with a
concrete layer I mean the government has
been negligent the opposition has been
as negligent because they hadn't
developed a counter position because
they're terrified of 50% of the people
turning around and hating them if it's
the fifth it seems to mean is it the
50-50 split that is the real problem
here rather than the politics well I
think I mean brexit itself is a problem
in let's be honest and and not pour too
much corn up on trees or maybe because
this is a an immense challenge which you
know most British Prime Minister's we've
already had in the past one of 20 years
we would struggle with but the real
problem is we went into breaks it
without it being defined the leave
campaign for a very successful campaign
but purposely kept it vague so there was
no actual proposition of what would
happen on the table and since then West
miss has been turned off he is fighting
to define that and it is know when he
then inject in
to that this colossal battle of egos you
know from Boris Johnson on one side to
the remain as George Osborne successor
on the other side it should be no wonder
it we've got to the state we've got to
so I think Theresa May was the only
person who isn't using brexit for her
own political ends
you got the Labour Party who want to
have another general election
you've got the ERG who are using Bret's
it to further their own ideas about an
economic system that they want and
you've got Boris Johnson who just wants
to be Prime Minister she is doing it but
she's doing what she's doing because
she's trying to deliver what she thinks
is you know the will of the people on
the basis of of the referendum we had in
2016 and you know you can't doubt her
sense of public service I don't think I
think it's a very poisoned chalice but
at least she seems to be doing it for
for unselfishly see I have a slight
disagreement with that because I do
think it's a it's a it's a tough job to
do but let's not forget she chose to put
herself in the position to be Prime
Minister somebody had to you though but
use the it'll grow not you don't have to
shape yourself forward and you know it's
a great privilege to be Prime Minister
of Great Britain secondly you know yes
it is it so if you go into politics it's
the most important job in the country
and you can you can do a lot of good
with it but also but also she chose to
rob herself of her own majority which
was a very stupid move in the snap
general election I think the mistake
that she has made is that she hasn't got
the politics of this right how
compromise may well be the only show in
town in terms of what what is the art of
the possible but the trick about
politics it's to make other people feel
like it's almost their idea to get them
to buy into that deal and she sort of
treated the public and her own cabinet
and the opposition like potatoes best
left in the dark and you know it's
unused to black the Irish actually but I
do think that she you know she could
have had she could have reached out a
bit more and she hasn't done that I mean
that history she's not very good at the
fraternity is she the quiet coffee
mornings chatting over we're not people
with the problem for her do you think
and in try teas not great at selling
what she's managed to do which is a
compromise which let's be honest the
European Union have signed up to this
well she does actually have a deal on
the table she
suade all the people back home to vote
for it I think where you can be credible
Teresa made and pretty heavily critical
is Ramona she's not just trying to get a
break still together and and get it
through the European Union she's also
trying to keep her party together and so
much of the delays this year I mean vast
tracts this year that I spent down in
Westminster chronically a delay oh no
it's not gonna be a decision time this
cabinet after all maybe they'll do it
next month and that's because she's
desperate trying to find a compromise
without taking her entire party with her
when the fact she's needed to lead it
and that leadership of her own party has
been lacking now Jenny you've opted for
a story with massive geopolitical
implications beyond Britain's borders
but which started much closer to home
remind us yeah I wanted to talk about
the poisoning of sergei and julius
[ __ ] and many other people actually
who got involved in the salisbury
poisoning the nava choke poisonings
which started in march but of course the
fatality was dawn sturgis who died in in
july as a sort of associated person who
is never the intended target this is
just an absolutely unbelievable story at
first it seems like a kind of spy movie
where you've got russian agents sent to
poison a double agent and then there's
kind of comedy aspects to it as well in
terms of this completely absurd and
slightly cack-handed way the russians
did this the the two russians who are
identified as being suspects going on
russian TV and saying oh we were just on
holiday we went there to beautiful
cathedral i mean you know I've been
there it's a great monument Russia for
the day just to see it so that that
would be funny were not for the fact
that it is also a tragedy because
somebody lost their life and I think
what all of this shows is the complete
contempt Vladimir Putin has for us as a
country that he thinks it in this very
quite half-baked way quite kind of
boldly you know not very sophisticated
way that he can send people over here to
kill people to kill British citizens to
kill people who have British passports
as Sergei secret file had and it's not
the first time we've seen it alexander
litvinenko Polonia to then you have you
have the same sort of situation where
there is going to be complete impunity
for the people who've done this in
respect though I think it's been a
really good thing in that the
international community has come
together there were 28 countries who
expelled Russian diplomats there was a
kind of very widespread condemnation but
ultimately there's nothing we can do and
that's a big success isn't it for the
British government and for Teresa made
that she managed to get this
international support to condemn and
criticize Russia and indeed President
Putin I don't think it is actually
because what Putin has recognized is if
you are the tough man of the world the
rest of the world will go bend over
backwards to get out of your way and
allow you to do it's an interesting
experiment with but that hasn't happened
in this if booties are 120 different GRU
agents expel from all around the world
I'm serious time it's people have been
expelling agents for about 200 years but
that's when they can't do anything else
it was an interesting so the thought
experiment is around skipper's say this
this gas say they dropped it in a sense
of Salisbury say they'd killed 10 people
or 50 people or 500 people at what point
would there be a moment in which Putin
has to face a reckoning broader than
having his his spies expelled and the
what what Putin has realized is to avoid
unpopularity at home he can stomp around
on the world stage he might get some
spies kicked out which you'll also point
to as a great conspiracy against him
from the West and actually you could
ratchet up the atrocities he took down a
plane a few years ago
he's annex Crimea is in again to eastern
Ukraine he knows he's in Syria
supporting a sad he knows time and time
again you can do things and the world
will always blink first
the American president was trying to
befriend you at the same time well many
of these things were underway including
their summit in Helsinki absolutely and
I think well look I think Stig makes a
very good point the the problem with the
Russian situation is that nobody really
knows how to deal with it and it points
pivots to a bigger question about our
bigger geopolitics we're very good at
talking you know in flowery rhetoric
about how it's really important that
nobody should do bad things but when it
really comes to it we are all
collectively pretty impotent apart from
using the usual channels and expelling a
few people and don't forget as well the
Russian interference in other
democracies in
the still the the ongoing Miller
investigation there's lots of
speculation about em cyberattacks and
you know disinformation and distortion
and disruption and I do think that the
the kind of the under the radar stuff
with Russia is very very difficult for
us in the West to even begin to
understand how to deal with I think this
was also your story of the year as well
wasn't it the broad ramifications of
what you do with President Putin how it
feeds into the you know the Russia BOTS
the Russia investigation in American
politics fake news all of it has really
sucked the life for really out of parts
of journalism and politics this mandala
is what can you do the UN was an
institution crater on the back of World
War two to enable us to take action
collective and people act improperly and
that just seems to have stopped not
least because Russia's on the Security
Council so they can veto any action that
might compromise their own interests at
the fact that we can kind of talk about
Putin's interference in the American
election a massive Democratic moment for
one of the world's leading democracies
it is now more or less accepted that I
saw a New York Times piece in the middle
of December saying things like they
targeted african-americans to suppress
the African American vote to turn them
against Hillary Clinton to stop to UM
persuade them not to vote that's traced
directly back to Russia and what do we
kind of do we shrug our shoulders a
little bit in it there's a question mark
about what did they get involved in in
the EU campaign and and once you allow
this state to interfere in other
countries when they know they can do it
with impunity where does it end
okay um we will move to happier times
because it's your choice now are you
sure lastly a little bit of romance for
us thank goodness a happy news story
what have you picked well I like to see
myself the Barbara Cartland do these
kind of proceedings I think that overall
Matt's is good it was the wedding of
Prince Harry and Megan Markel no you're
not I like to boost stop it it was a
kind of a rare good moment where the
country genuinely came together and
there was a lot of love and goodwill and
it was a historic moment as well because
not only was Harry taking off the the
best bachelor you know lists of the
world it was a big deal for Megan
Michael to enter you know the blue blood
of the royal family
a woman from America a divorcee and most
importantly a woman of color entering
the royal family and I thought that was
an incredible moment I sort of looked
like the royal family was leaning into a
bit of modernity and you know we've had
a pretty rotten time in our politics
this year and it was just a rare moment
where the whole country stopped sniping
at each other for just a few hours and
it was kind of nice boy do we do
weddings well I mean that's a one thing
we can do Brittany figure it breaks it
figure poutine we can throw one hell of
a bit of pomp and ceremony tremendous
and a great advert for Britain at a time
when you're leaving the European Union
one might say yeah I I thought the real
star of the wedding was story of Ragland
who is Megan Michaels mother who was
just so poised and so graceful and so
alone the only member of her of her
family it was a remarkable thing to
watch and I'm not a massive royal fan
but it felt like a kind of pivot in
history actually for our country and and
and you know good on them could I drop a
note of cynicism what's happened in the
in the six months since M has been if it
was between two men it's very catty
reporting about women bitching my point
this this strong woman as you say a
woman of color and I do think that makes
a difference visually I think it's
important people to say this is how
Britain is moving forward but what we've
seen is can the royal establishment
handle mega marker without leaking out
that she's difficult you know the
difficult woman narrative is already
become can the press handle as well
because as you're actually right you
know we were fighting this young
beautiful couple and that is this
almighty backlash happening against her
as well let's hold on to those sorts of
that successful tour down under and the
Royal Wedding as we move in and withdraw
the cynicism hey you dude that's what
that's what we were after thank you very
much now coming up tales of tremendous
bravery unlikely diplomacy and good old
sporting Redemption as we toast our
heroes of the year after the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching
year-in-review on Sky News we turn now
to the newsmakers who brought people
together in a year when conflict was a
recurring theme our panels heroes of the
year and I know Stig and Aisha you've
made the same choice haven't you a group
of people who endured enormous hardship
but found a happy ending very difficult
this for them weren't there you picked
the tie divers and all those who helped
in the rescue yeah this was just an
incredible story I mean it reads like a
film script and it does have this remark
yeah absolutely and has this remarkable
happy ending so the the boys got stuck
in a cave and then lots of divers
British divers had to go in and help
them and it was very very precarious
people did not know if they were going
to be rescued it was done in real time
there were lots of issues in terms of
not having enough oxygen left the the
water was rising they didn't know if the
boys would be able to stay calm enough
to do what was quite a paquius swim out
it was amazing but the thing that really
struck out for me was the positivity
around the the story even the parents of
the boys there wasn't this immediate
blame game going on about the coach it
was almost like there was so much of
goodwill that I think that genuinely
made a difference and the coach who took
the boys and there must and was stuck
with them he was an absolute hero so he
must have felt the weight of the world
that he'd made this terrible decision
and it had all gone wrong yet he kept
them calm he kept them motivated he had
good advice about sort of not drinking
the water which was dirtying about you
know taking the water from the ceiling
incredible things and the divers are
amazing as well because we live in an
era of really selfish people who try to
put themselves forward as self-appointed
heroes and these guys are the most exact
solutely and these guys are the most
modest genuine heroes and they didn't do
it for fame or for money they just did
it because that's what they do
and it's only when you put yourself in
the situation of being in darkness where
the threat is as you said of waters
rising you know miles from help not
knowing if help is coming that you truly
understand how absolutely terrifying
that is we live in a very small world
really where you feel ultimately if you
get into a mess
experts people will be able to get you
out actually they were in a situation as
you say where they were underground for
two weeks the the whole cave system was
gonna flood on the 10th of July I think
was the points we was gonna flip they
had to get them out by that point even
when they discovered them which was a
massive feat in itself by divers and
there's that great video footage of them
say how many of you are there near 1313
brilliant you're all there they still
have a think of ways it's about not
onlys about courage and bravery it's
about mental abilities he had to work
out solve the problem of how to get
these boys out when they weren't divers
there were huge leap malnourished they
were they were scared and that's why the
coach to me is is the here meditating
waiting a bunch of teenage boys in a
cave for two weeks and he got them
meditating and he got them up but a
diver did die obviously so there was a
tragedy at the end of it as well for a
father and sure the level of peril
associated because even I remember being
on the papers and when they've
discovered the poison and then parmie
thought I'll find them discover them
that's it it's out it's over and of
course it wasn't over the fact they
managed to get them out just by using
ingenuity and teamwork and people from
around the world coming to hear pitch
darkness in pitch darkness the most
amazing exploit and it reminds me and
then Elon Musk coming in to offer a
submarine and then accusing making
horrible allegation about one of the
yeah reminds us what absolutely pompous
indices also the contrast so what was
going all the time and you know not to
go back to brakes it too much but brakes
it was not game particularly well Donald
Trump was having multiple rounds with
different people all around the world it
felt like a pretty pretty miserable time
in the world for this sort of brightness
to be injected back into everything the
contrast it was tremendous well let's
get to a meaty issue now that of North
Korea Jenny I know you've chosen a
peacemaker
already someone who tried to broker
peace who he chosen I have chosen moon
jae-in which perhaps viewers might not
know that name very well he is the
president of South Korea and he is the
real hero he's my hero because his job
was to stand between the two biggest
egos on the planet and their nuclear
weapons and defuse the situation which
he did very well he was elected in 2017
at a time of ridiculous threats between
Kim jong-un and Donald Trump Donald
Trump's calling
Kim Jong and rocket man there are
intercontinental ballistic missiles
being tested left right and center moon
was elected and said I am going to
create a better and better relations
with the north and he did and there was
the Winter Olympics in South Korea where
the Koreans walked together in the
opening ceremony and I think was ice
hockey that they played together and
then he had summits with Kim himself
amazing pictures from the border I mean
you did credit you have to pinch
yourself when you see stuff he'd given
the backdrop of what was happening
earlier and then of course he managed to
facilitate the meeting of Donald Trump
and Kim even though it was canceled at
the last minute he managed to again be a
peacemaker get this and the summit
itself the Singapore summit I feel quite
uncomfortable about because it was
basically a photo opportunity
legitimizing a dictator and showed the
world that if you want a lot of
attention what you should do as the
dictator is develop nuclear weapons but
nonetheless later on in the year I think
it was in August some of the most
remarkable images that I've seen this
year were of South Koreans and North
Koreans who had been separated for 65
years mothers and sons family members
finally seeing each other so moving all
to do with this one man who was prepared
who knew that in order to make this
happen he could never take the credit
for it and he had to let other people
take the problem with all of this is it
puts the North Korean leader in a good
light tens of thousands of North Koreans
still flee to get South they're still
being staffed and held in terrible
conditions and on the other side moon
jae-in his parents were from North Korea
he wants to unify the country which is
deeply controversial in South Korea so
there are awkwardness awkwardness
awkward moments rather in in in much of
this story I think certainly but I think
diplomacy is a lot better than
threatening threatening to murder
everybody with nuclear weapons which was
basically what was happening in 2017 if
you had told us 18 months ago that we
would be at this situation now nobody
would believe it Kim Jong Un's role in
all this is really interesting as well
as knowing that without a shadow of
doubt moon is the hero of the day but it
did take him in to meet him halfway you
know that that's a DMZ that the
demarcation zone which they fought over
or potentially fought at Sony exchanged
artillery shells over for 50 years
he met him halfway and arguably is
because his nation is on the verge of
economic collapse he's worried Donald
Trump is gonna invade but there is I
would never call the man here because
he's clearly desperate and an appalling
dictator but there is something that
happened there that that made him come
halfway to that he's a poet picture he's
now been legitimized so that that I mean
the massive downside is he still has
camps in which people are murdered and
the American president can actually talk
about Kim jong-un in terms of positivity
without being censored so there is a
there's a casualty this is the man who
stole his uncle's two dogs yeah and
we'll move on to another big event in
the summer Tom this is your choice some
journalists through and through perhaps
and you've gone for a populist choice
from the world of sport it was the World
Cup in particular the manager of the
England Football team gave South Cape I
mean admittedly didn't mr. waste save
huge amounts of lives or or and the
Holocaust
it was a dark summer that's been a dark
yeah maybe another talk year coming up
and there's this wonderful period of
four weeks and the mid June to mid July
we could just forget about that from
undream and fine they didn't win the
thing and you know arguably they
struggled just a bit too much against
Colombia with penalties for God's sakes
as Colombia but it was the modesty of
the man the way he did it and his calm
relaxed assured performance and roomy he
had some wonderful tweeting and social
media content he was putting out saying
maybe the England Football team is the
way for for the country maybe we can
come together maybe we can achieve
things more together than apart and and
if it doesn't get a knighthood any time
soon it will be never mind those lofty
ambitions we actually won a penalty
shooter but he of course was so scarred
by his experience our hero 96 it's a
story about how to how to how there is
life after enormous failure and
humiliation and also actually David
Cameron well yes no but also this idea
that actually made the England Football
team kind of likable again the people
were proud really proud you know they
there was something about yourself yes
exactly
that's just a year of the loudmouth
isn't it because it's a year of thought
we're living in
in times and Gareth Southgate is kind of
I would agree in an era of strong men
you know and so toxic masculinity he
suddenly it was like you can be a
gentleman you can be kind to people you
can be compassionate it's okay to be an
emotionally intelligent man and
everybody wanted we scooped okay still
to come it wouldn't be panto season
without a bit of booing and hissing so
the team will scold their villains of
the year when we come back welcome back
this is year-in-review on Sky News we
are dissecting the highs and lows of
2018 with the editor at The Times
Literary Supplement stick able the
Evening Standard columnist Asia has a
recap and the sun's political editor Tom
Newton Dunne and journalists and
documents maker Jenny Clayman welcome
back to all of you so having cheered the
heroes of 2018 it's now time to jeer the
villains anyway Jenny let's start with
you who said you riled up this year
Boris Johnson's got me really riled up
this year and I'm gonna I'm gonna talk
you through exactly why so in June when
he was still foreign secretary he missed
the Heathrow crucial vote on the
Heathrow third runway and went on a
nine-hour
trip to Afghanistan one of the few
people in the world for whom Afghanistan
is a sanctuary he of course it's said
that he would lie in front of the
bulldozers to stop the runway from
happening because he's a coward because
he didn't want to be there for the vote
and then you've got in July he of course
resigned after the the checkers deal he
resigned I think about 30 minutes before
Theresa May was due to speak in the
House of Commons designed deliberately
to harm her as much as possible whereas
all this was on a Monday that he
resigned and on the Friday he had been
toasting her and toasting her kind of
long reign as Prime Minister he
obviously he's had a difficult year
himself he announced a separation from
his wife because he you know it was
revealed that he was in love with a
mystery blonde himself of course but no
in all seriousness
he had he had affair with the woman who
he was linked with was eviscerated in
the press newspapers went through her
Facebook got lots of pictures of her and
then in August he's writing you know
dog-whistle columns calling women in
burkas
you know letter boxes and and bank
robbers and and whatever and behaving
very badly at party conference he does
have you are you were gonna carry on but
he has florida language he's a great
writer as it is you know he is an
opportunist and a coward and he does not
care about brexit he does not care about
Heathrow he cares about forests it's
okay I would just like to back up
everything my very good friend says and
on the point you say about him being a
good righty I don't think he's a good
writer he regurgitates the same stuff
over and over again and the point that
Jenny made about the Muslim women do you
know attacks on Muslim women went up
after that column so I think you know
you to have you know great a platform
like he does you have responsibility
with it and I think he's shown himself
to be really unfit to be Primus possible
that all being said it is not impossible
this may be a testament to the state of
the country it's not impossible that
after all that he might still be the
next British prime minister I think I
think his time is gone I mean I would
not really want to offend Brussels I
will say one thing he does speak for
some people and you know you may not
like breaks it you may not like romaine
but he does speak for millions and I
have to tell you I don't think he's
gonna be promised it I probably didn't
he should be Prime Minister no but I can
tell you that millions of our readers do
really like him because he can community
also know they gave him foreign
secretary a chance to show could he be a
figure on the world stage and he
demonstrated unequivocally that he could
not you don't know all the see well in
the visible world stage ask their family
of an Iranian woman whether he was a
good foreign secretary or not he's being
outperformed as foreign secretary by
Jeremy Hunt we told you this was the
villain section didn't worry certainly
stake the object of your scorn
definitely won't be the next leader of
the Conservative Party why not it's
David Cameron is my villain because
everything we talk about to do with
brexit every single problem that syriza
may face
is that the country faces as we go into
2019 should be laid at the door of David
Cameron who to solve an internal party
squabble not only considered to have a
referendum would you have a debate where
that's a good thing he did in explicably
didn't put a threshold into it so it had
to be a certain percentage of the vote
for changes significant as this which
they did in 1979 for Scottish devolution
it's absolutely possible to do because
the root cause of all our brexit ills is
as a 50/50 split country and David
Cameron who blagged the 2015 election he
blagged the Scottish referendum he
thought he was gonna black number 3
coast through as he always did and
instead he put the country into chaos
because he was incapable of looking
ahead and seeing what might happen if
the country but don't you think the fact
that leave won that vote showed it was
right to put it to the people no because
I think the problem is a 52-48 in either
direction spells ruin for our political
systems Thomas said earlier it's broken
Parliament the reason it's broken
Parliament is it's a 50/50 split if
you're going to have something that
absolutely alters the very structures of
the country it has to be on more of a
mandate than that and that's that was
not only wise in in hindsight it's a
massively apparent at the time and it's
found to him his whole attitude towards
government tom knows embezzlement he
might say I'm wrong here
he believed he can coast it he's a
coaster and he's put the country
coasting into chaos and that's why I
blame him visit everything we see
decades of strife and division over Joe
major did as well for example so it can
bricks it and the political or the
broken politics we have subsequent to
that can that be laid at Cameron's door
no it can't and I think you can accuse
Cameron being severally confusing be
arrogant a bit conceited having a
slightly overrated opinion in himself he
went to his final EU summit to tell the
leaders to back him cos he's a winner he
didn't win but the Tory party's troubles
of Britain's troubles with Europe
Britain's
terrible schizophrenia about whether
we're part of you or not has been going
on for decades nay centuries and I think
to lay everything at Cameron's doorstep
isn't quite right but then by the way
that was 2016 he's probably
20:18 very quiet this is sitting in his
shed while the ramifications continuing
we need to move on we've got so much to
pack in if you don't mind Tom I know you
came face-to-face with your villain of
the year back in July who is he
I was rather grateful for coming it was
the president of United States the same
suit I changed my shirt got 10 seconds
prettier with the president and it have
time to put down my rubbish carry a bag
at the time have the operation with
POTUS you need to put those right sum it
up them anyway why so despite his
kindness in in in grunting me 27 minutes
of his time in the u.s. embassy in
Brussels I think you can trace not just
a lot of the world's strife this year
but also in future years to come we have
we have yet to even see the start of
down to this one man the one thing I did
learn sitting in that embassy talking to
me he is all-powerful
nobody contradicts him nobody tells him
to stop talking our interview was
supposed to be 10 minutes he ran it to
27 he told his press oh shut up
basically and he makes decisions really
like a feudal Moloch and you look at
those decisions this year so we've
talked about North Korea already he
legitimized Kim jong-un in nuclear peace
talks are going precisely nowhere he
started a trade war with China
the ramifications of which will play out
for certainly the US but also global
trade for for years to come he pulled
out the Iranian nuclear deal
a rather seismic event in May which has
been slightly forgotten about
potentially destabilizing in an entire
region and making Iran want to start
enriching as he rhenium again if he
doesn't think it can trade with the US
and the US has played on his banking
system and all this and of course Remmy
sat the room with Putin and and
legitimized said god only knows what
deals they cracked up this is America
under one man pulling out of the world
system and I think it's going to be
really dangerous but he shakes up the
world order he shakes up politics and he
speaks for people in America who feel
like they're not being heard he does and
this is true he's found a way of
communicating with people who felt they
haven't been heard of for years and
years my purse
complaint with that is of what he's
saying to them is potentially quite
dangerous and actually the answers he's
offering are not really answers and
Aisha president Trump angered a lot of
people when he appeared to ally himself
with your choice who are you talking
about it's society crime Prince Mohammed
bin Salman and he is a very interesting
figure he's seen as a hugely powerful
figure in Saudi Arabia at the beginning
of the year he tried to get some good PR
by allowing women to drive however I
think that was a bit of a distraction
because actually lots of women who had
campaigned for this were being tortured
Saudi Arabia still has an appalling
human rights record it's a medieval
country in many many ways and then of
course later in the year he is
implicated in the murder of the
journalist khashoggi and he is somebody
who seems to you know have a terrible
attitude - and the rule of law he sort
of pretends to be a modernizing ruler he
absolutely isn't and it's interesting
that Saudi Arabia and America have such
close links and I think one of the real
regions to watch for next year is going
to be Saudi Arabia and also as Tom said
whether there will be some kind of
intervention in Iran so I think bin
Salam is a very very interesting
character yes as all these strong men by
which we mean all he Annan kind of
normalized when when when when you know
and the murder of khashoggi led to
Angela Merkel canceling weapons deals
with Saudi Arabia but but the murder of
countless people in Yemen fuelled by
weapons sold to them by Britain has
scarcely and we rolled out the red
carpet for his visit this year and I
think there's a very very big moral
question that is being asked by
governments there's no easy solution to
this and Trump was very defiant about
this which was where do you draw the
moral line and where do you draw the
economic line in terms of both our
countries do a lot of business in terms
of honor sales
wasn't it he he said I'm not going to
destroy US jobs for this moment and they
haven't and they have haven't properly
censured the Trump administration
Mohammed Ben something do you think
about the script hole poisoning that we
all of those Russian diplomats have been
expelled you're basically the same the
same thing happening that you have a
Saudi national killed on foreign soil
and yet we are still continuing we sell
them arms we train their police we host
their dignitaries you know if NBS is is
of is a villain we are complicit in that
we have weird villains to the bodyguard
with NBS in London at the time was of
course the chief suspect for chopping up
reporter anchor shogi in Istanbul
there's also security relationship it
was very important to add in what has
extra complicating element to our Asia
with Saudi Arabia turning your back
entirely on salary up now we're on how
Pauling NBS might be would do
irreparable damage to the Britain's
security closed-off huge amounts of
intelligence it's a very very tricky
problem if any Prime Minister to run
deal with ad yet 14 of the 18 911
bombers were Saudi al awful lot of the
most extreme Islamic ideology comes out
of Saudis one of those great mysteries
to me that Saudi Arabia in Yemen they
are killing citizens doing double tap
strikes where they go in and then kill
the first responders as well their scene
is this country we need to ally with the
security reasons and yet an awful lot of
the world's terrorists are funded by and
come out Saudi Arabia okay a plenty more
still to come when we come back our
panel read the tea leaves to predict the
stories we'll be talking about next year
join us after the break hello and
welcome back to the final part of our
Year in Review we've run the rule over
2018 so now let's look to 2019 and our
panel's predictions for the year to come
stick why don't you kick off I wasn't
allowed my main prediction the country
would plunge into ever greater chaos but
I said it in more fruity but let's leave
that to one Sykes I'm sure we'll get to
that in other predictions
I actually think next year might be the
year of the technological backlash
I think that we are all collectively
still very glib about the risks of
giving up data to people like Facebook
to various other parts of the internet
we what we demand convenience we want
people to send adverts that we're
interested
the damn we want to do one click but
this this year has shown we talked about
Putin's influence there was the whole
scandal around Cambridge analytical
where Facebook was making information
available for nefarious ends there's the
beginnings of a recognition I think that
we've all had too much too soon when it
comes to technological generosity and
without recognizing the risk and I think
next year we know it's compromising our
health it's compromising our ability to
sustain relationships it means we can't
ever close the door on the world and I
think that change will happen where
people just think it's not worth it
anymore so are you talking about
personal dating personal use of mobile
phones or whatever it might be or are
you talking about the fact that data is
being mined the combination of - we have
to take personal responsibility we have
to recognize that we give up all this
information then it's used and I also
think that big super companies like
Facebook and Google will start to face
regulation Facebook has it it is bigger
than most countries when it comes to
economic health we could see the British
Parliament I can't call Zuckerberg to
account because he's more powerful than
the Prime Minister of Great Britain and
America is the same thing I just wonder
whether we'll get to the point where
Facebook's got too big Google's got too
big we all recognize that technology
while giving us benefits is harming our
collective health and the backlash I
think we'll starting to realizing if
something's free then you're probably
the product you know that they're
getting something from you isn't it yes
ten years to crack well supposedly you
know hiding behind this guise of
bringing us all together and being I
think as well people are really starting
to question the effects on mental health
and in particular with young people as
well and I think a time we will look
back on this time a bit like the tobacco
companies when they first started up and
you know we will I think there'll be
much more regulation of social media
going forward so past the crystal ball -
Ayesha what does the future hold as far
as you're concerned well in terms of the
breaks essential crisis we find
ourselves in but I think that and the
chance of there being another referendum
is increasing and I think this is
because of the maths in Parliament
Parliament is completely stuck and I
know the idea of a second referendum is
very very controversial but when
everything is so stuck and I'm not
saying I would love the idea of a second
referendum but here's my analogy think
of
break set in Parliament being like a
block toilet right and what you need
it's a dirty job it's a block trying to
think of a second referendum as the
plunger to unblock things it's a dirty
job it has to be done of the series this
thing needs this dirty thing needs to be
unblocked sending it back to the public
well you could have a question on the
final on the final I think you have to
give people the final say on it
particular in Parliament has proved
itself incapable of sorting well it's
just very very quickly on that story
what do you think will happen and bricks
it oh gosh don't ask me that I hope it's
not going to happen I think it's a
terrible act of self harm I do think
that if we're going to do this to
ourselves there should be a better
mandate than than a vote that happened
two years ago Tom your best guess I
really don't know the one thing I do
know I'm pretty sure about is it won't
happen on 29th March I think it's that
the brexit day is going to have to be
extended because the pickle is too deep
to untangle dig I think I think there
will be a second referendum location I
can't quite work out how we get to it
but also I'm not sure I don't think
romaine will necessarily win and I'm not
sure the mandate that we get out of it
will be any clearer and I don't wanna
blame David Cameron wouldn't you open
the door to this and you split the
country it's very hard to get resolution
even if you're asking what happened to
Theresa May which takes us to your
thought for next year Tom yeah so this
is a bit of a punt to do more of a punt
saying that be a secondary referendum I
think by this time next year when we
invited back to this comfortable sofa
that will have a different prime
minister who will be aged under 45 and I
stand to be proved wrong and I've been
wrong with everything the last two years
Oh Jeremy Corbyn thank you so I'm afraid
that rules out Jeremy coffee my theory
is this the current generation we talked
to this at the top of the show me
talking about breaks in my theory is
that the country is now fed up with the
current peripheral class but also the
party members are pretty fed up with the
political class and they desperate want
a new face and some new change and
actually look in the terms of the Tory
party you won't know who these people
are you
I happen to know who they are who are
you talking about them so for example
there are people Torian Peas
Richie sunic is a good example he's a
junior government as two elected three
years ago
working very hard in Department of
paperclips at the moment but a very
impressive orator really good think
another example can be bad a knock
Nigerian heritage has a brilliant way of
explaining talking to people both Rishi
and kami are levers or they're not sort
of the the more extreme wing another one
Johnny Mercer former Army officer great
friend Kate Burley he's got stopping
around the country with K for a long
while
thirty-seven years old again a very
straight talking guy tom to cannot again
another one early 40s
former Army officer now chair of the
Foreign Affairs that community all these
people elected in the last three or so
years all of them very front-facing and
interesting and offer promise you're
somewhat presuming that the Tories will
still be in charge there has been a
general election and in fact mr corbyn's
been voted in absolutely and I think one
of the reasons just leaping back to my
projection one of the reasons I think a
second referendum is is likely it's
because a general election is very bad
news for the Conservatives at this stage
now the polls at the moment sure that
the Conservatives are still slightly
ahead but I think you can't really test
the mood of the public until you in the
heat of a general election and Corbin I
think whether you agree with his brakes
at position or not has definitely jumped
in position whatever he's tapped into a
very deep sense of frustration that a
lot of people have about some of the
reasons that drove breaks it austerity
cuts the public services so I think
there's a huge chance Corbin could come
in not necessarily with the majority but
definitely enough to form a corner that
sort of takes us to Jenny's point a lot
of the theme of this this hour has been
broken politics and the parliamentary
impasse so what is your prediction then
well my prediction is something that
won't happen but really should happen
which is I think the Conservatives and
the Labour Party need to split into two
parties each their left wing and their
right wing factions need to cleave off
from one another so that we do not waste
our time with the ridiculous infighting
that has been crippling our politics at
the moment and that we can actually have
more choice these are I think what
brexit shown is that binary choices
aren't necessarily very good for the
country we need something with it with a
bit more nuance and hopefully this will
lead to that unblock egde of the giant
demands we've been to all manage it
the counter view to that because I am
naturally a sort of a centrist politics
person but when I go around door
knocking and just go around the country
doing things what a lot of people say to
me is do you know what I love the fact
that the next general election we could
have a true socialist leader in the
labour party and we want a true blue
conservative a lot of people want those
primary colors because they have felt
that politics has been too much you know
the same types of people there's not
that much of difference between people
you're all the same and I think that's
one of the reasons we are in this very
disruptive phase so I think people like
us might think that oh it's terrible but
I think for a lot of other people they
feel quite enlivened by the fact that
there's primary colors back in Johnny
Mercer who's going to be the next prime
minister said he wouldn't even vote
conservative he can't vote for his own
party so does he have in common and I
think the tribalism is breaking down
quite a bit actually I mean I think that
the core be Mabel was a far more about a
reaction to the status quo and the where
capitalism appears to be going pretty
badly wrong brexit itself could well
create this this brand new president
when labour and Tory MPs are forced to
go a line and walk through the lobbies
together because they're two different
extreme wings when do it suddenly things
could move really quickly okay there's
so much to pack in that is just about
all the time we have for our Year in
Review thanks to stick
I assure Jenny and Tom will almost see
you soon on the press preview but for
now from us all good tidings and good
bye
[Music]
you